[Musique]
il est temps de dire au revoir aux
grandes déclarations
c'était chouette en fait nous
aujourd'hui c'est de glisser à droite
plutôt qu'à gauche on ma qualité de
remontée désespérée du coin j'ai le
malheur de vous annoncer que l'amour
romantique n'existe plus ok je vais
retirer tacconi quoi pourquoi lorsque de
vie amoureuse et pas intéressante
t'as qu'à la rendre plus diverses en
techrine chronique sur le sexe mais ya
pas de sexe certains trucs je te ferai
galy tel chronique n'était pas
intéressante
cette année j'ai gagné 67 mille dollars
en cadeaux
est-ce que je suis une prostituée non
est ce que je suis croqueuse de diamants
fait bien
alors est ce que tu vas te baigner il
aime bien les arrangements je pourrais
lui parler merci tu serais pas obligé de
faire des trucs tout t'as pas envie
j'aimerais bien te revoir tu vas le
fréquenter non c'est trop fait sa valeur
s'explique pas vraiment sexy
il était charmant l'auteur doit devenir
l'histoire pas seulement en faire partie
ce faire demandé se prostituer c'est pas
une de l'histoire ce qui importe c'est
la suite c'est ça qui nous intéresse il
y avait quelque chose qui me plaît chez
lui qui arrivait pas identifié alors au
diable la gêne
des gens riches plus âgées entretiennent
des gens plus jeunes moins fortunés n'a
rien de révolutionnaire
peut-être que les relations ne sont pas
censés être dicté par l'amour mais par
la survie pourquoi est ce que t'as pas
de petite amie il faudrait que je perds
mon temps avec des messages et de textos
les disputes une relation avantageuse
sur le plan financier je me faisais
entretenir
la romantique désespérée est ce qui
attire le plus d'attention
j'ai adoré temps derniers articles
écrits pas d'article mois alors c'est
pas moi ok la chronique et anonyme
pourquoi t'es pas une prostituée c'est
pas le bon moment là ça fonctionne pas
comme ça mais je sais pas comment son
canton en ligne peut-être bon sens
exactement comme ça mais en journalisme
qui suivent une histoire pas seulement
des sentiments parce que ça va on serait
rendu au moment du film la situation
semblait désespérée mais on n'est pas
dans une comédie romantique des années
[Applaudissements]
seulement mon histoire
[Musique]
je m'emmerdais alors j'ai mis un peu
d'ecstasy dans marées cette non
est-ce que ça va j'ai pris de la drogue